عباد الله ان الله تعالى امرنا بامر بدا
فيه بنفسه وثنى بملائكه قدسه وثلث
بالمؤمنين من عالمي جنه
وانسه وقال تعالى قولا كريما تعظيما لقدر
نبينا وتفهيم لنا
وتعليما ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على
النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلموا
تسليما اللهم صل وسلم وبارك واكرم وانعم
وتحنن وتعطف على سيدنا محمد طب القلوب
ودوائها وعافيه الابدان
وشفائها ونور الابصار
وضيائها وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد الفاتح لما
اغلق الخاتم لما سبق ناصر الحق بالحق
الهادي الى صراطك المستقيم وعلى اله وصحبه
حق قدره ومقداره العظيم جزى الله عنا
سيدنا محمدا صلى الله عليه وسلم بما هو
اهله جزى الله عنا سيدنا محمدا صلى الله
عليه وسلم بما هو اهله جزى الله عنا سيدنا
محمدا صلى الله عليه وسلم بما هو اهله فيا
ايها راجون شفاعته اكثروا من الصلاه
والتسليم عليه فان صلاتكم نور على الصراط
حين تمرون
عليه ان
سست are لا fr
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الحمد لله رب
العالمين استغفر
الله
another استغفر الله
الله سبحانه
وتالى are the
year
not
riew
your
life الله سبحانه
وتالى
استغفار pleas for again
place
difficult but we more
please you can ent in
[Silence]
خطبه
خطب خطب
about
ح
grand مي عليه
السلام الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران
[Silence]
قران number
19 سوره
مريم عليه السلام
‏j
هارون
said which means
الله
would زكريا
[Silence]
‏refuse and
said we
should lot to see who
her so they went a riv to
[Silence]
زكريا عليه
السلام الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏divine knowledge from the from
theen which we reveal to
you and you not among
them to
عليها
[Silence]
السلام محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
رانكر عليه السلام عليه
السلام
يحيا ح mar
jes ‏upon
him
could it
notation from الله سبحانه
وتالى and
this and this is a of theh
truthfulness and that
is صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتعر
her
be so
was and ob
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
قران time
زكريا her
would
would proved for
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
قران زكريا
[Silence]
الله الله prov
for
account جابر بن عبد
الله
الانصاري رضي الله تعالى
عنهما صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏days محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏any فاطمه رضي الله
عنها صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏i
h said no iwear by you my father and my
mother when he her house i sent a
messenger girl
who and me
‏said
الله الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم حسن
حين م الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
فاطمه صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏when i
at inside i
was because it was filled with
food
ied bl الله سبحانه
وتال صل الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الله
الله for
he
account the
prophet
الله الله
[Silence]
الله and
say
الله الله
م صلى الله عليه
وسلم علي رضي الله
عنهن علي
فاطمه حسين
حسن صلى الله عليه
وسلم all
‏even after fin ea
there so so
that the
ne the صل الله عليه
وسلم
اللهصلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلمون
خديجه
فاطمه الله سبحانه
وتعالى قرانك
‏upon his
lord oh my lord gr me rous
children
and also informs us that zaria was in
desp of having children because he
haded as as wife
‏when
mir مم عليه
السلام children with his wife even
though was
old and ان شاء
الله زكريا عليه
السلام يحى عليه
السلام ان شا الله
تالى
regarding jes عل السلام
so
here الله
bl
all that الله
for all my par
اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين واعلي كلمتي الحق والدين اللهم
اغفر لنا وارحمنا وتب علينا
وسامحنا واختم بالصالحات اعمالنا اللهم
انا نسالك خير هذا العام وخير ما فيه وخير
ما قبله وخير ما بعده ونعوذ بك من شره ومن
شر ما فيه ومن شر ما قبله ومن شر ما بعده
ونعوذ بك من فت الليل والنهار ونعوذ بك من
شر كل دابه انت اخذ بناصيتها ان ربي على
صراط مستقيم اللهم علمك بحالنا يغني عن
سؤالنا اللهم غير حالنا الى احسن الاحوال
اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين اللهم فرج عن
المسلمين في كل مكان الف بين قلوبهم يا رب
العالمين اللهم ارنا الحق حقا ووفقنا
اتباعه وارنا الباطل باط ووفقنا اجتنابه
اللهم وفقنا للعمل بكتابك وسنه نبيك صلى
الله عليه وسلم واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله
رب العالمين ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء
والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واقم الصلاه يرحمك الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمد